so season three so fun that you two are
part of it corbin was a bit trippy being
an og high school musical cast member
and returning the series and not playing
yourself was it immediate yes to be a
part of this franchise again uh
first part of the question's so trippy
so surreal uh just living my own
inception
life uh of just layers upon layers upon
layers within a dream and uh as far as
the the easy yes um
tim
federly as the one who actually had had
reached out personally uh and he
i i i can't tell you enough how
comfortable he made me to make it such
an easy yes um
one because i i knew that already he he
valued the franchise itself and and what
it means and to have seen the first two
seasons and and how how
well done
it was and just to shoot through through
that perfect lens of still being able to
to make light of it and at the same time
really
having amazing performers amazing talent
amazing music um
but know that you know he was
my arc and and what it was going to
be for me uh coming coming back to the
series i i knew that it was it was going
to be uh
just right
well we love seeing you back on it so
we're really it was a really good time
so and jason we all know you're from
hannah montana of course iconic but you
work in the cast as acting coach for the
first two seasons
so um maybe a lot of people didn't know
that and they grown up all so much so
great job but would you say grow
grown the most
uh that's a really good question
actually um
you know i think the person who
i really have been
blown away with his matt cornette i
think matt came in and he was playing
sort of
he was like sort of the mean jock guy
you know and it was a little i i think
the original intention was a little more
one-dimensional
of a character um and i think he was the
one that was the least comfortable like
dancing in the show and he's worked so
hard with uh vocal coaches uh with our
choreographer uh he's
he looks really great in the numbers um
he's much more more confident and then
he's so lovable as a person and he works
so hard as an actor that i think he's
really fleshed that character out and
he's not just like kind of a a jock who
does plays he he really is a a very cool
character
who you root for um and and my favorite
stuff like this season it is the season
of fun so like when ricky and ej are
sort of goofing off with each other as
opposed to being rivals and being really
intense it's it's such a fun interaction
because they're they're like that in
real life as well um so i think i think
watching like matt's growth over the
last couple of years has been pretty
fantastic
no he has his character and just himself
in general he has definitely grown so
much and i wanted to ask both of you
guys what's your favorite high school
musical the og songs
ah um
i'm gonna have to say the boys are back
uh just because
the experience of shooting that number
was so memorable we used it was a night
shoot uh and especially as a
as a teenager at the time it was just so
cool to just
be up all night long till the sun rose
just at work and um
the it was all also that that number in
particular everything that we had at our
fingertips um
when i still go back and watch that
number i i think
kenny's
creative direction on that was so
brilliant uh and the choreography in
that number too when i watch it i i go
back when i
i hadn't watched it for a long time
and once i
signed up to do this i actually had gone
back and and watched some of the old
performances and uh
i i was blown away
i love get your head in the game
and mostly like from from a messaging
standpoint because i i work really hard
uh i i hold like myself and my fellow
actors accountable like i expect you to
be prepared and ready to go and it's one
of the things that i stressed with the
kids as the acting coach the first
couple of years and so just sort of that
mentality of like guys we have a thing
that we gotta do we gotta focus it's
time to get your head in the game like i
just just on principle i i love that
song
okay great that's our time for today so
thank you guys so much
you